i saw something where uh you said that
you learned how to fly a helicopter
because you looked into the banking
system
am i wrong i mean what's going on right
now yeah you almost got your motorcycle
right like i was on a [ __ ] airplane
sitting flying across the atlantic to
london
sitting next to a guy who was on the u.s
rowing team going he was going to go
compete in [ __ ] finlanders how
shredded was his back
seven
and he's sitting there reading this book
by neil strauss called uh like [ __ ]
how to survive some survival guide thing
and i was interested because neil
strauss wrote the motley crew book and
he's like this epic writer what can i
say talk about a wide variety right
i guess it's all about survival if you
talk about motley crue
these guys somehow survived bringing
motley crew and going to singapore
so this guy
explains what the book's about he's like
oh well in in the case of natural
disaster or economic collapse or you
know nuclear or whatever like and there
was just in a whole variety of scenarios
which represented
[ __ ] hitting the fan and the first thing
you gotta do is get the [ __ ] out and he
said that this guy recommended
motorcycles because you could split
lanes to get out that's great it's a lot
cheaper than a helicopter license
but uh so dude so i turn around and like
the next part i only have a two-seater
too so i'm going to make a sophie's
choice
who's coming who's staying well
i know i'm going
i i turn around and [ __ ]
and enroll in motorcycle school because
that because i bought onto the idea of
this you know that's cool though but
then you learn something i know but
here's the [ __ ] thing dude like what
did you write
as soon as i enrolled in motorcycle
school and i enrolled and it's going to
be like another
weeks before i actually have the the
classes
as soon as i enrolled every single
[ __ ]
everywhere i went someone's like oh i
get to go visit somebody in the hospital
they were like you know they perfect
motorcycle
motorcycles just kept coming up in
conversation and it was always the worst
[ __ ] thing and then when i got there
to the actual class i realized that like
you gotta have like a clutch on the
motorcycle and i've never even learned
how to drive stick in my life so while
they're trying to teach me i'm like oh
well
[ __ ] you know like you gotta remember
the clutch and it just delays your
reaction time and and already like i'm
just like i'm a dead duck i can ask you
a
question
when you were in the cause i took the
motorcycle safety course and i got my
license and all that i wrote for like
two months and someone else took my head
off going over the double line in a turn
and i remember like coming back i was
running a triumph bonneville and i was
literally shaking
and i was and it's funny because i never
pray
so i dial up god for the first time in
years it's like oh look who called
what do you want
bill just say hi do you
this [ __ ] guy
puts me on speaker
[ __ ] right so i [ __ ] um
i just said if you let me get back
to dean delray's garage without losing
my leg or my life i swear to god i'll
never ride this [ __ ] thing again and
i didn't but now i kind of got it back
again and i'm thinking of getting like a
dirt bike just to ride around i
fly out of this little little ass
airport and i'm just just gonna ride
around there where it's safe so i still
have the skill yeah so i know how to do
it because i think that they're they're
[ __ ] bad ass man i i but when you
took the class didn't you look at a
couple people just being like why this
person's gonna die right i remember that
that was
the first day was in a classroom the
second day was in a parking lot and the
third day was in a parking lot and i
[ __ ]
quit after the
the first parking lot day i i'm a
motorcycle school dropout
no it didn't it didn't just you could
have just completed it because you would
have gotten i know but but here's the
here's the thing and then you know how
to do it you don't have to write i
almost shouldn't say this but but after
my
first day in the parking lot actually
riding the motorcycle i had a date
later that night with like
i didn't want to say anything i'm
[ __ ]
really like she was like
voted by maxum magazine like the seventh
hottest woman on the planet
the next day to get up and the next day
you have to go to class
and when she asked if i wanted to meet
her dogs i did
and i never left
that's a good excuse for not
completing that's all right some of the
hottest woman in the world and he landed
on like motorcycle accidents and deaths
i said i said you know what i'm not
gonna go to motorcycle class i don't
that [ __ ] was gonna [ __ ] kill me
those guys ride motorcycles so they can
meet that [ __ ] you like pre-emptiness
what do i need a motorcycle for
yeah is get road rash in my dick
yeah wow looking at the stats i just
don't think it's right it's not safe
and then you just raw dog the random
safer than riding a motorcycle
the air is a lot safer
the uh
the how often do you fly your helicopter
well what sucks is right now because i'm
involved in this i'm not allowed to fly
okay they're like they'd say okay you
can try and kill yourself after we get a
cut of them
of the movie so
um i haven't flown since uh february
right before uh because i didn't realize
that but i mean i went up with an
instructor or whatever so uh i'm like
you know really safe and those
you know
as my instructor says aviation is as
safe as you are and you would be
surprised like that there's only two
types of pilots pilots that know they
can die and then the other people who
just show up like i mean [ __ ]
pre-flight
just [ __ ] cranking and just take off
you look at their whole attitude when
they take off it's like dude if you have
an engine failure right now you're just
gonna nose into the ground or you see
people like flying super low
flying really slow it's like you're dead
if your engine dies you don't have
enough
altitude to regain your air speed to
keep this [ __ ] thing going to go into
a flare like an auto rotation and you're
[ __ ] dead so they there's like
you know with anything dude there's like
these major
things that if you implement them you
look at the weather you do your prefix i
only fly when it's nice out i only fly
up to a certain knots of of winds
because i mean i mean i can fly in it
but why don't be up there [ __ ]
bumping around and everything
and you know you can you can get the
odds
in your favor and now like you should
see like i'll show it to you something
like the cockpit i have all glass
cockpit and i'm literally like an air
traffic controller now with the uh
with the technology where you can back
in the day
when i first started flying like you
were just talking to people you didn't
know where anybody was it was just them
reporting so if you went out you know
east day here where all these [ __ ]
yahoos are who aren't they don't even
talk on the radio and all of a sudden
i'll go flying by you and you're like
dude what the [ __ ]
now you can see them coming you can
literally like put your finger on the
screen and their tail number will show
up and you can talk to them the arrow
points in what direction they're going
there's a thing that says plus six minus
five i mean 600 above you might so you
know exactly where the [ __ ] they are is
that bad for drug smugglers huh
i got a good one for you
uh instructor told me uh you know when
when any time the vice president or the
president comes in town there's just a
massive tfr wherever they are
uh uh temporary flight restriction like
you're not allowed to fly in there and
if you do you're warned and then you get
intercepted by like a [ __ ] i don't
know what you know an f-16 which
wouldn't work with the helicopter
because you fly so slow they'd have to
keep going by us so they probably sent
some sort of presidential level uh
secret service helicopter up there um
there was a guy uh flew into a tfr
didn't do his pre-flight and that's one
of the things you do you look to see if
there's because you get major [ __ ]
trouble if you fly into one of those
even if you just fly over dodger stadium
two hours before the game yeah there's
two hours before the game and after
because there's gonna be all of those
people they just you know don't fly over
that if you fly into that the faa is
calling your tail number i mean i don't
know what happens i don't want to find
out what happens so this [ __ ] idiot
did not check
and he flew right into it and he wasn't
on the radio and he got intercepted and
they landed and it turned out it was a
drug smuggler coming up from mexico
which usually then you're not going to
be on the radio but at least fly around
the [ __ ] and they forced him down and he
had a whole plane full of drugs and that
was it and if he had just looked at his
tfrs he could have still been bringing
cocaine into this country
yeah you can't even fly a drone over
daughter stadium during the game where
you go to jail i mean it's pretty did
you play drone over dodgers during the
game no
dude there's a guy and they can't find
him and i don't understand why the guy
has a [ __ ] jet pack
yeah and he's he's been hovering
right outside like every couple of
months he'll just be there
at dodger stadium no at lax and he's
he's sitting there like he's at [ __ ]
buck rogers
so my thing is like how many people buy
jet packs like we can't get some people
on this so the funniest [ __ ] ever that's
online you have to listen to the radio
calls
is there talking to somebody flying in
anywhere from three to six hundred
people yeah yeah just let you know after
the left you got a guy in a jet pack and
then the pilot's like yeah we see him
and everybody sees this [ __ ] and he's
just
and yeah they don't know who he is right
it's like a mystery i don't understand
on what black market this guy bought
this [ __ ] jet pack
because i remember i was watching the
first 48 one time and this [ __ ] idiot
bought a 50 caliber desert eagle and i
guess not a lot of people have them and
they killed somebody with them and they
just went all right who bought a desert
eagle they had it was like you should
become the first 48 minutes
they [ __ ] caught this guy
in like an hour that's the best show
ever
yeah well i i got a buddy of mine former
cop hates that show cause i was watching
that show going like i don't understand
why they keep talking i'm like all you
do is say am i being charged with
anything if i am if i want a lawyer if
not i'm leaving he goes that's why i
hate that show because it teaches dirt
bags how to beat the system the worst
one i ever saw was they brought this guy
and they go and there's some old guy
that was got murdered in the park then
they say to this guy he's a suspect and
they go
they go hey do you know old man johnson
or whatever
he's like yeah yeah i know him you go
you're good friends with him because
yeah i see him around he goes uh well uh
i hate to tell you this but we uh we
just found him in the park he was
murdered and the guy just worst acting
ever he stands like what oh man
i didn't do it
just sign the confession
and you just literally watched a guy
it takes somebody's life away and just
throw their whole life it's like that
guy is going to jail for the rest of his
[ __ ] life he should have taken an
acting class because when his moment
came he would have been ready she should
have watched the first 48. yeah yeah
[ __ ] lawyer you ever you ever see
that picture of the ramirez brothers
court side like an hour before the
menendez
like the twin brothers or whatever
there's like a picture of them at a
basketball game sitting courtside
everybody's like cheering and they're
just like straight faced
it's an eerie [ __ ] picture and
they're like this was like two hours
before they murdered their parents
isn't that weird
it'd be weirder if they were like stoked
and like cheering and happy you know
yeah
that just reminded me of you remember in
scarface
when there's the comedian on stage and
everybody's cheering and all of that
stuff and everybody's watching and
tony's cooked in the corner everybody's
dying laughing to palma just pans across
and there's two people just sitting
there
like that and the ones with the uzis
under a napkin i love the oozies under a
napkin like at some point they just took
them out and then put
would you like something to drink hang
on a second let me just put this right
here
where's like let me get that napkin like
no don't touch the napkin leave the nap
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]